think i only had one bad meal in la um
what was it was it the attack shame them
yeah yeah yeah okay oh my god yeah dude
you remember this do you remember this
i think i think on like the third day or
something that we all arrived together
we wanted to go to one italian but it
was like uh it was like a sad day was uh
look at the bat we were originally gonna
go to boca de beauvo because i [ __ ]
love it but yeah yeah as god was saying
it was a weekend so we were like a book
of the pepper is probably gonna be
really [ __ ] crowded so let's find one
on the way and then we found this uh one
italian place i don't even remember that
it was like family earned we thought oh
that'd be that'd be good to support a
local business yeah exactly exactly
and maybe we shouldn't have
how do i regress yeah and i forgot like
the one golden rule of like like how to
judge a restaurant which is if it's peak
time on saturday and you go in and it's
almost empty that's that's a bit that's
a big red flag
also to do with this restaurant i had
been told this and i come from japan
right if a restaurant has four stars in
google
it must be good yeah exactly good
exactly apparently in america if it's
not higher than 4.5 it's dog [ __ ] is
what i've been told really that's what i
was told is it the 4.5 4.5 is apparently
the like if it's higher than that it's
you can you know it's good right right
maybe americans are nicer do people just
rate in america four stars if the food
is edible i i don't know so do you
remember when we got there like yeah
we got absolutely scammed right away oh
yeah right so
so we pull up into this restaurant right
and
there's clear parking spots right yeah
so and there's valet though there's
valet parking right no one is here no
one is in this restaurant this may be
like
we should have turned back at this point
honestly yeah so we go in the we gotta
start parking our car and this guy comes
over and he knocks on the window he's
like oh uh valet service eight dollars
and we we i think we misunderstood that
he we thought that he was like oh you
have to pay it right right but i think
it was you offering it yeah
so we were like oh okay so then we get
out the car hand him the eight dollars
and he literally just continues backing
it up into the spock and gets out and is
like all right there you go this is
probably in the car for about eight ten
like 10 seconds tops that man got the
biggest conversion of time to to payment
and known history it's like those memes
of like bill gates when he drops a
hundred dollars on the floor it's like
it was literally the car was basically
parked and then he just went that's it
and i couldn't believe this man took our
money i couldn't believe he was still
willing to take dollars for that i'm
like only and only in the us i'm like if
this happened in the uk fist would be
thrown if you try to get the eight
dollars off of me it
we all stood there and we were just like
we just got robbed yeah yeah we we this
is like
i can't believe you've done this yeah so
yeah we uh immediately go into this
restaurant after losing eight dollars
um and then afterwards we go in and
looks pretty it looks like a pretty
decent restaurant um and so
sorry no
say something yeah
sorry yeah i don't like it when
restaurants do this and this is just for
me preference i understand that people
don't care
if i'm in an italian restaurant and
you're trying to like set an ambiance
don't [ __ ] play an mlb game in the
corner on a giant monitor
like i'm sorry to me it's like that's
not the italian vibes are ruined but
there was just like two giant sports
games and they were just playing the
audio and i'm like
also there was a very american looking
bar in the middle yeah yeah yeah well
that's fine i don't care about the bar
being in the middle right i just it's
like i think i think it's got a mood i
think it's i think it's the bar in
combination with dmob on the screen that
just made a very non-attack yeah it was
like two giant like 50 inches on the
wall blasting this audio and you're just
like eating your thing and you say and
that's a strike and that's a
there you go
and it's just like ah this is just like
what am i am i crazy like is this weird
this is weird right yeah so i i get you
i get you because i like i don't like
that in restaurants either where they
play a game or something like that okay
yeah at a bar okay i get it i get it
it's it's a bar yeah yeah there's a time
in a place it's a bar it's a bar this is
this is a restaurant you know
i would prefer to you know just have
some music and uh just have that set up
if you went on a date there you would
look bad that's what i'm saying yeah
ambiance would already make it look
you're in a rough spot
better make up for it yeah i mean like
everyone ordered their food and of
course of course i was like i gotta try
the lasagna all right all right because
i i think that's my default thing i
order every italian restaurant that's
like that's how i gauge how good the
rest of the italian food is right
because you'd have to like try an
italian would have to try really hard to
[ __ ] up a lasagna sure because there are
way more like complicated dishes in the
italian cuisine so i always rewarded
lasagna um
and then
i will say the guy did look a bit
panicked when you ordered the lasagna he
was like
okay
he's like oh that one yeah he was like
oh you're ordering that one i was like
it's been a while since i've had lasagna
and of course it it comes out and it's
probably been an order it's probably
been a while since they ordered it yeah
it comes out and i'm just like oh that
looks that looks a little soggy
that looks like a little bit of a soggy
lasagna it was it was something like
what twenty something dollars yes it's
like twenty anything like this but it
wasn't like a giant piece either no no
no no normal size it's like a 28 like
but like all the dishes in that
restaurant were about like yeah they're
all at least twenty dollars eight
dollars quite a lot of money it's a lot
of money um and i like
i put my fork into it and it just
[ __ ] this this pasta just
disintegrates right this thing wasn't
made out of pasta it was made out of air
and
and i'm like i've never seen pasta so
soft in my life yeah and i take it i
i take like my first bite and you know
when you can immediately immediately
tell that you're just like the worst
meal of your life yeah so god looks so
disappointed
everyone everyone was like staring at me
because i because they were so excited
because like oh go and order lasagna
let's see let's see what he thinks about
it i take one spoonful i think my face
conveyed everything that needed to be i
wish i had taken a photo of the face
that you had made because it was like if
you looked up disappointment in the
dictionary that was the face
because the first bite first of all the
pasta was soggy all of it was soggy yeah
it somehow even though the pasta even
the lasagna was like full of tomato
sauce somehow they've made tomato taste
nothing taste of nothing like i don't
know how you make tomato taste of
nothing because it just it was cold on
the inside right as well and and it was
cold it was so obviously microwaved yeah
as well because the hot the outside was
super super hot but then the inside was
lukewarm and i was just like this is
this is yeah to the restaurant's credit
my dish was actually pretty decent i
think i had like a uh a lamb pasta it
was pretty good actually yeah i like uh
like a gnocchi i think which was like it
wasn't the best gnocchi i've had but it
was it was decent i know you should you
get lasagna to see if the restaurant's
good yeah i feel in my mind if i get the
calamari that's how i can normally tell
because the calamari is one of those
dishes where it's really easy to buy it
frozen yeah and just deep like just
chuck it in the [ __ ] deep fryer and
just call it a day but like if they
actually care you can tell that it's
it's fresh and it's not [ __ ] rubbery
and then you know it's everything else
could be good because that's a very
specific thing that you'd have to go out
of your way to make sure it's fresh
that's true that's true but that was bad
i mean like it wasn't worth the money it
was just too expensive it was so
expensive it was yeah it was definitely
i mean the gnocchi was like decent but i
would not pay the amount i paid for it
again yeah yeah i mean like one one of
my biggest pet peeves when i go to a
restaurant is that
i'd like as someone who grew up in like
the whole restaurant kind of like area
you do you sh if you can't make a good
dish don't put it on the menu like you
know what i mean like there are some
restaurants i go to where they give you
the menu and it's just the entire
history of your country's cuisine i'm
like there is there is no [ __ ] way
you can cook all of these dishes
and like a good kind of snack oh no
there's like 200 items on the menu it's
like
yeah i get it if there's that one guy
comes to your [ __ ] restaurant he's
just like oh why don't you have this
dish that everyone else has you know i'm
just like you know [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you know just serve good just serve the
dishes that you know you can cook really
really well five to ten items i feel is
like i feel a good middle ground because
it's like you know maine's yeah okay
like five to ten mains i think is like
the good middle ground because it's like
you know those five to ten means are
gonna slap we went to another italian
place that was really good around the
same price and it was amazing oh yeah so
good oh yeah the one we went with uh
yeah yeah yeah
and it was i think it was around the
same prices for like everything yeah
yeah and i thought wow okay well so it
isn't just like i'm i'm being cheap it's
like no these are the same prices we
just got ripped off in this one yeah
yeah but that's how it is and that made
me understand more like when i went to
more independent uh restaurants and more
uh coffee places a lot of the time i
kind of understand why a lot of people
just want that familiarity of a chain
well you know what you get because it's
such a gamble in the u.s
oh it's a gamble everywhere yeah but
like in japan you like
you you've got to be pretty unlucky
like you talk about the u.s being a
gamble let's talk about the [ __ ] uk
the uk
this is the same though this is why like
restaurants in the uk like and cafes
like a lot of the independent ones
struggle because a lot of people don't
like they want that familiarity yeah and
they want like you know when you go to a
[ __ ] wendy's you know exactly what
you're getting sure whereas if i go out
of my way i i take a date i pay a [ __ ]
ton of money and i get a half-assed meal
pastor i'm like [ __ ] i should have just
gone olive god like i know what i would
have got yeah yeah because we we talked
about the us having like the 4.5 google
reviews kind of meta the uk just doesn't
have a meta when it comes to google
reviews you just like people in the uk
don't know how to review food that's
just that's just the end or be all the
water was not spicy five stars
because i've been to restaurants in the
uk that's like 4.7 4.8 i'm like okay
this place must absolutely slap it's
awful
like really there are some places that
are out there
like the ratatouille critic
i'm about to end this restaurant's
career hold on hold my pen
to be fair to be fair i've like see in
recent years especially this trip i have
discovered way more decent restaurants
in the uk that i that i had that i did
than before i moved out of the uk i
think that i think the uk have just
definitely upped their restaurant game
um
because i don't know what you
experienced beforehand but this was the
first time for me that i probably
explored explored london and like the
food culture surrounding and i'm like
why is what are people complaining about
this is actually pretty decent maybe i
just got lucky i don't know but yeah we
just have we just steal other people's
food and uh you know that's good
i mean australia kind of does the same
thing yeah we don't have like a cuisine
it's like what do you want like there's
probably someone here who makes it like
church do you want like new zealand rat
i'm sure
someone
[Laughter]
because i remember when when we went to
the uk i think maylin landed and i think
two days after she landed she'd had like
four meals and she'd message me being
like in all caps do reviews not mean
anything here
how do you know who to trust how do you
know which google review to trust and i
was like do you review things i don't
remember i review things really oh i
never i never even looked at google
reviews before i moved to japan oh okay
yeah right now
because i just looked at something and
i'm just like oh that looks i'd look a
couple of photos i'm like yeah that was
good yeah i review things i feel like
people like me are keeping society
together without me there won't be
there's such chaos how will everyone
know what did you always review though
oh yeah i've been doing it for a long
time okay so before you move to japan
yeah before i move to japan because like
i understand the culture here because
you review something it means something
here yeah you throw you throw a review
in the uk google reviews it's just like
a message and you throw a [ __ ]
message in the bottom into the sea like
it's not going to reach anyone man it's
like a message in dark souls
i am guilty though of the whole
five-star or one-stop meta i am guilty
of that what do you mean i'm either a
five-star guy or a one-star guy you've
never rated anything three stars no i
have i just like in my head
if something's three a lot of the time i
want to go back and confirm it's a three
yeah but also why would i want to go
back to the three because you're kind of
indifferent to it right yes i'm like
yeah whatever yeah yeah and like some
places i
like a lot of the times i've gone to
restaurants i've ordered one thing and
i'm like uh and then for some reason
i've gone back and i've got a different
dish and i'm like oh oh this is just
this is so much better this dish like i
just happen to get the dish that they do
poorly right you could argue that that's
like reflective on them and they that
they shouldn't put it on the menu it's
better whatever but i feel like it can
vary so much whereas like if you have a
five star time you're like everything
was perfect it was amazing staff were
amazing ambiance oh everything was
amazing right all right well five stars
where on the on the inverse side where
it's like if it was all [ __ ] i i knew it
was all [ __ ] right she's terrible so you
just nip it back yeah so never go
right
but a lot of the times i
the places i go to in japan are just
purely off recommendations yeah so
i kind of normally go to places that
i've always really liked i've i've not
gone to many places that i haven't
enjoyed in japan yeah because everyone
is always like this is my favorite
restaurant so i go tricks i'm like oh it
must be pretty good i mean yeah at the
end of the day word of mouth i think is
the most effective way of finding oh
dude
yeah honestly some play some places in
japan aren't even on google reviews or
they're not on it if you just search
restaurants near me or something like
that yeah next kind of restaurant i'm
looking for sometimes you have to like
really really look uh and that's why
word of mouth means so much here in
japanese food culture because people
follow what other people say and if you
see a huge line at a japanese restaurant
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] slaps even
though i never think it's worth waiting
an hour for any meal in my life sure
sure [ __ ] that yeah i'll go to
mcdonald's
i'm not waiting an hour
now inside the restaurant drinking i'm
not waiting yeah yeah yeah
not in the line usually in this heat in
japan
it's not worth it
what's like your limit
of waiting well outside of a restaurant
yeah 20 minutes tops i'm not doing more
yeah for me it's like no more than 30.
yeah i think 30 minute is the absolute
limit it really depends like okay if we
have like 20 people and they say 30
minutes i'm like we're waiting 30
minutes we're not going to find
somewhere else so it's like but if it's
just me and someone else 20 minutes tops
yeah and it's got to be a restaurant i
know otherwise i'm like 10 minutes yeah
because it could just be a huge waste of
time and the food is kind of mediocre
yeah i'd rather just go somewhere if
like if you're in an area where there's
a bunch of restaurants nearby i'd rather
just go somewhere else just the name
yeah just yeah
that's true yeah one one small thing
that annoyed me in some of the
restaurants we found in la was that you
know sometimes we we were in a group we
wanted to go out have a nice meal
together all right let's phone up the
restaurant and book a table and find out
the restaurant they're like we don't do
bookings yeah there's like a thing in
l.a right turn up in the door and i'm
just like why why
yeah a lot of the restaurants we went to
wouldn't accept i never understood why
that's the case is it so to avoid people
flaking out i think
i there must be some math behind it
where someone has worked out that you
can make more money and get more
customers in the door by doing it just
turn up right because if they're full
and you can't reserve then you're not
going to show up but maybe you want to
go maybe they can squeeze you in if
there's two of you right i feel like for
the restaurants that are in really high
demand it must make more money yeah
because you can get more customers in
yeah yeah people are willing to wait 20
15 minutes at the door right right so i
i feel for like yeah like what was it
like sugarfish whatever
sugarfish was one of them there was i
mean
we went to the first italian restaurant
we went to before we found the other
italian restaurant yeah yeah that was
that was the big deal because also when
you when you go one day and you can't
get in you're like i should come back
again because clearly it's good
everyone's waiting and and to be fair
the restaurants where i did have to wait
we're pretty damn good um i i feel like
yeah it's a strategy to just make more
money and also you don't have to deal
with reservations not showing up yeah i
think i think that makes more sense to
me than because you you lose money right
if you have a table and they don't show
up or they shop 20 minutes late or 15
minutes late or they show up 20 minutes
early and you're like
it's not ready basically they've just
min-maxed restaurants right
but but you know when there's a group of
like four or more preserving is like
amazing because it's like we know that
we can turn up at this time and we'll be
good and japan's great for that that's
why i love japan yeah because you can
reserve any or most places except except
for a danny's it's not it's not even
japan in most places in the world i've
been to there's rest most restaurants do
reservations and three two to like i've
okay let me let me rephrase that i've
never seen this system ever anywhere
outside of la i've never have you ever
seen it out anywhere outside of valley
i'm sure it's in like new york a place
like that you call them up and they they
say no reservations yeah there's places
that just don't take responsibility
other than like
donald's is a restaurant all right
a family restaurant
for families i guess so yeah
because you know because you know
throwing it back to the time we tried to
reserve for seven people
and they were like we don't take
reservations just show up please i'm
like oh yeah
we'll pay
we really want that
need to denny's
yeah